you had the pleasure of performing
infirmed live audiences but walking out
on that stage yes yes so different it's
I think over 6000 people like seven oh
my gosh
it was like a wall of sound it's so
exciting
yeah it's so exciting I've done the
Shakespeare in the Park in New York
where people wait for free tickets and
you perform that night and there's an
energy when someone is a fan and really
really like put in the work to come and
be there and there were people last
night sleeping over to be here and when
you walk out there you really feel that
energy it's so it's so inspiring and
exciting that concert oh my gosh it was
phenomenal it was phenomenal it was yeah
it's such an ever been to this event
before so it's been really cool to be a
part of enjoying this franchise I mean
we have been over the last few months a
TT like trying every which way to ask
everybody like are you in are you in are
you in are you and you guys can finally
talk about yeah right totally totally
it's I think it's gonna be a fun as the
movie starts to roll out there's lots of
really amazing pieces and parts of the
movie that we're not a lot of talk about
but I'm like a little kid at Christmas
waiting for it to come out because it's
I think people are gonna really love it
who do you play I play Christoph he was
in the first movie he's the blond
mountain man that's right you are the I
mean he said give it a rest Jonathan I
know I guess that's the image you're
saying we got to do what Josh demands
you it's done do it it's over
sorry fun yeah Jack said we gotta go
yeah that's a wrap I do want to ask
though about because this is like
celebrities center today I mean anybody
who's everybody and everybody who's
anybody is right in this place have you
had one of those moments like holy smack
you know I'm obsessed with Tina Fey so
she was here for her movie soul that
she's doing a voice and it was so fun to
talk to her and then I'd never met Tom
Holland before and he was so in a daze
so cool and so easy to talk to and you
would think someone in the early
moenay's would be like so scattered and
you know understandably distracted but
he was so lovely to talk to and such a
nice person and we had such a great
conversation I will say Tina Fey is
leading the charge on people that I've
asked today like who they've kind of
freaked out about their that she's been
over in genius yeah she's a genius and a
legend yeah I love it
[Music]